le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais beaucoup de personnes
subissent au cours de leur vie un
événement pouvant provoquer un grand
choc émotionnel parfois ces personnes
ont du mal à surmonter cet événement et
trouvent refuge dans la consommation de
certains produits cela peut être
l'alcool le zamal ou d'autres substances
dégradant le corps et l'esprit ensuite
c'est
l'engrenage tion répété devient une
dépendance et sans aide il devient très
difficile d'en sortir alors qui peut
apporter son aide existe-t-il des
méthodes ou des organismes qui
s'occupent des personnes atteintes
d'addiction on en parle maintenant dans
lien
social il y a plusieurs années Marie
Lorine a perdu son mari mère de deux
enfants elle a dû surmonter sa peine
mais aussi celle de ses enfants
mais suite à ce tragique événement son
garçon a commencé à avoir certaines
fréquentations qui l'ont malheureusement
entraîné dans la consommation d'alcool
et autres substances très mauvaises pour
sa santé physique et son intégrité
sociale Marie Lorine a bien sûr essayé
de maintenir son fils dans la raison
mais la dépendance a pris le dessus et
le dialogue a été rompu entre elle et
son fils à ce moment submergé aussi par
sa propre peine et celle de sa fille
marielorine doute et on arrive même à se
rendre coupable de la direction que
prend son fils vraiment en détresse euh
ne plus savoir où j'en suis à dire que
j'ai pas j'ai pas été une bonne mère que
euh
je j'ai j'ai détruit la vie de mon
garçon donc
euh voilà quoi c'est euh euh bah c'est
après que j'ai décidé j'ai dit non il
faut pas il faut pas baisser les bras il
faut taper aux porortes qu'importe où
mais trouver une solution pour pour que
mon fils s'en sorte consciente de la
détresse de son garçon marieloren a
redoublé de courage et d'effort pour
trouver des solutions elle s'est donc
tournée vers un dispositif mis en place
par le Conseil Général SOS
zamal son fils ne voulait pas recevoir
l'aide venant de ce service mais Marie
Lorine a pu y trouver des personnes à
son écoute lui proposant des solutions
pour rétablir le contact avec son garçon
en fait je suis je je suis plus rassurée
parce que au moins j'ai une personne qui
m'écoute qui qui est prêt à et est prêt
pour m'aider pour que mon fils s'en
sorte donc que ils vont faire tout le
possible
pour pour que il vient là-bas et se
fasse soigner ça se passe mieux parce
que avant j'avais pas de dialogue avec
lui du tout maintenant je peux dialoguer
avec lui quand je lui dis de faire
quelque chose à travail ou faire la
vaisselle il le fait maintenant c'est il
est en train de de de de de
changer mais le problème c'est que moi
je voudrais
que dans sa tête ça fait un déclic que
dire il faut que il arrête voilà comme
ça il puisse aller de l'avant trouver un
travail faire sa vie bien comme dire
demain matin bah si je dois fermer les
yeux ben je sais que mon fils est sorti
de de tout ça il y a plus il y a plus
dans sa vie il y a plus de drogue il y a
plus de d'alcool il y a plus rien il a
une bonne vie une meilleure vie que ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a traversé grâce à SOS
zamal Marie Lorine a trouvé une épaule
sur qui elle peut se reposer elle y
trouve une écoute et un soutien qui lui
permet d'aider son fils à s'en sortir
bien sûr elle va devoir encore faire
preuve de patience et de persévérance
pour arriver à sortir complètement son
garçon de cette spirale infernale mais
elle sait maintenant que ce n'est qu'une
question de temps et qu'elle va pouvoir
trouver des solutions et apporter une
réponse à son problème oui nous avons
souhaité au Conseil Général mettre en
œuvre dès l'année 2012 un dispositif que
nous qualifions d'innovant puisque d'une
part il est
multiartenarial d'autre part il touche
un public qui est sous dépendance à
certain nombre de de choses sont pas
bonnes pour leur santé Zama les gens
passent et ce public là on va le traiter
différemment avec d'abord une approche
individuelle ensuite une approche
collective donc des ateliers collectifs
on va faire intervenir des des
associations spécialisées dans cette
question là donc une volonté pour nous
de cibler ce public de lui venir en aide
d'une manière plus efficace pour lui
permettre d'échapper à cette spirale qui
le sort peu à peu de la société et qui
le rend entre guillemets un peu associal
ou en tout cas mal dans sa peau donc ce
dispositif qualifié de SOS zamal je le
répète est un dispositif qui est utile
et qui a l'avantage de prendre
l'individu dans toute son intégralité et
de faire intervenir de nombreux
spécialistes au travers d'appelier
collectif Marie Lorine n'est
malheureusement pas la seule maman
confrontée à ce problème la dépendance
touche un public large à la Réunion
comme ailleurs c'est un problème que le
Conseil général prend très au sérieux
SOS zamal voulu par la présidente
Nassima Dindar en est la preuve il
propose aux personnes victimes
d'addiction d'être reconnu écouté ces
personnes sont très souvent en marche de
la société ce soutien leur permet de se
réintégrer pour redevenir acteur et
retrouver une vie sociale normale comme
tout
réunionnis le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté des
Réunionnais